some movies are seemingly cursed in
everything that could possibly go wrong
does go wrong take for example chaos
walking starring spider-man and Rey aka
Tom Holland and Daisy Ridley it should
be a surefire crowd-pleaser so why has
the studio declared it unreleasable
chaos walking is based on a trilogy of
books by novelist patrick ness the story
takes place on an alien planet called
new world settled by Puritan like humans
who left what's presumably earth more
than 20 years before the events of the
first book the knife of never letting go
on this planet all living beings can
hear and see one another's thoughts in
the form of an unrelenting cacophony of
images words and sounds which everyone
accurately calls noise in other words
it's chaos walking what if you couldn't
get away what if he really couldn't get
away what if there was no escape as the
plot unfolds a teenager named Todd finds
a place where there is no noise he flees
the male only settlement apprentice town
and meets a woman named viola which is
remarkable as nobody knew there were any
non males a new world eventually there's
a showdown between human settlers and
the intelligent native race called the
spackle in 2016 it was reported that Tom
Holland was cast to play Todd and Daisy
Ridley was all set to play viola
Lionsgate grabbed the rights to adapt
and produce a chaos walking film way
back in 2011 at the time the studio had
carved out a lucrative niche for itself
as the company that made all the major
big-screen versions of super popular
young adult novel franchises having
already brought Twilight from the
bookstore to the multiplex and with the
first Hunger Games movie on its way
chaos walking seemed like the next
logical step some major players started
to surround the project Robert Zemeckis
the filmmaker behind Back to the Future
and Forrest Gump was supposed to direct
but that deal ultimately fell apart
though he remained on as a producer it
was perhaps a sign of trouble to come
that there was apparently a struggle to
find a director to commit to a project
with so much potential along five years
after announcing the project Lionsgate
revealed that filming could begin in the
fall of 2016
now with Doug Liman in the director's
chair with Lyman behind the camera
filming on chaos walking finally
commenced in August 2017 in Montreal by
that time the rest of the cast had been
filled out with such notable names as
David Oyelowo Demi and Bashir Mass
Mickelson and Nick Jonas the shoot
seemingly went well but the results of
the tireless and expensive efforts of
cast and crew didn't quite meet studio
expectations
according to Lionsgate employees close
to the city
the first cut of chaos walking turned
out so badly that studio executives
deemed it quote unreleasable it cost a
staggering 100 million dollars but it
was apparently so awful once assembled
that it wasn't fit for public
consumption
so Lionsgate cancelled the film
scheduled March 2019 release and ordered
up extensive reshoots that would cost
millions and take three weeks to film
if Studios invest a fortune in a major
movie and a rough cut seems lackluster
it makes sense to spend a few more
million on reshoots in recent years for
example Justice League and Shazam have
made headlines for reassembling casts
and crews to film extensive new scenes
not long before their scheduled
theatrical releases to generate new
script pages for chaos walking lionsgate
hired Patrick Ness the novel's author
while Ness likely had relatively little
trouble pinpointing just what was
missing from the adaptation actually
filming those scenes proved difficult
reshoot plans were announced in April
2018 but cameras didn't start to roll
until April 2019 the reason was that in
the time after principal photography
wrapped the careers of stars Tom Holland
and Daisy Ridley exploded ultimately
there was a gap of about 18 months
between the first and last scene shots
holland and ridley didn't quite look
like teenagers anymore meaning that they
would appear strikingly and
distractingly different from seeing the
scene when lionsgate kicked off
pre-production on chaos walking in 2011
sweeping movie series based on
best-selling young adult sagas were all
the rage the four Hunger Games films
took in more than 1.4 billion dollars at
the domestic box office while the likes
of The Maze Runner and divergent also
performed well but within a couple of
years the dystopian young adult trend
was starting to lose its luster the
third divergent movie did so poorly at
the box office that a wrap-up finale was
cancelled and standalone adaptations
like the fifth way bombed hard by the
time production on chaos walking began
in earnest in 2016 the writing was on
the wall that this was a movie past its
sell-by dates but there are still plans
to get it into theaters at some points
as of summer 2019 it's tentatively
scheduled for release in 2020 but for
now it remains a film in limbo as
confusing as the chaos in its title
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]